Britain says it will issue thousands of emergency
visas to foreign truck drivers to help ease
supply chain problems that have led to fuel
rationing and empty shelves at supermarkets.
In the aftermath of Brexit, thousands of foreign
drivers left the U-K, since they could no
longer work visa-free.
And now ordinary Britons are feeling the effects.
Chaos at the petrol station.
Despite government pleas NOT to panic buy
fuel, long queues have built up at the pumps.
A shortage in lorry drivers has led to delivery
bottlenecks across the UK,
forcing some stations to close or to ration
what fuel they have left.
A nightmare for those who depend on the fuel
for work.
It's stupidity that we're all queuing up.
But this is my job, so I have to have diesel.
That's it.
I'm in here for my work.
I never know where it's going.
So I've got to have diesel.
Look at my tank.
I don't fill up usually, I leave it.
But look at that, it's empty.
How am I going to get to work on Monday?
You with me?
I'm done.
I've been to three stations.
Analysts say the driver shortages were caused
by the pandemic and Brexit.
Various sectors had previously warned that
supplies would run short.
Many supermarket shelves have been left empty
for weeks.
The UK government, facing growing pressure,
has now announced a temporary visa scheme
for 10,500 lorry drivers and poultry workers.
But this will hardly be enough to ease the
pressure.
Estimates suggest the UK is short of about
100,000 heavy goods vehicle drivers.
"I think we need is a bit of political pragmatism
here.
We`ve got an absolute crisis in the supply
chain facing us.
Of course there are political principles involved
in this, but there's also the principle of
making sure that people in Britain get their
food and their fuel."
Frustration among citizens is growing, too.
"This is Brexit personified.
-- Why is that?
-- No truck drivers.
All the foreign nationals who are Europeans
have left the country because of Brexit."
And with Christmas around the corner, the
situation could get even worse.